it's a classic office dispute she stole  your stapler he ate your lunch what up  it's gotten bad there's only one way to  resolve this with a cupcake battle  player1 get ready  player to get ready  the rules are simple it's like dodgeball  except you get hit in the arm you lose  that on you get hit in both arms then  you're pretty much screwed if you get  hit in the leg you lose that leg if you  get hit in both legs and you fight from  the ground  best you can the head or torso  let's incent debt catch a cupcake and  you get a fatality blow players get  ready jump back miss miss  let's shop  miss Blake  big colony whoa  sayonara sucker game Oh office disputes